[Music]
what's up guys I'm kvhd here and welcome
to my something called an everyday carry
video or what's in my bag what's in my
tech bag uh backpack video so I've
watched a whole ton of these videos
they're all over YouTube and they all
feel they're super badass and way more
nuanced and complex than mine so like I
didn't feel the need to share my bag
because it didn't seem that great like
you can ask people I don't really carry
that much stuff on the regular and it's
not even like really a tech bag per se
but the more I thought about it the more
it felt like
actually the fact that it's Unique in
that way may actually make it worth
sharing so maybe you'll enjoy it it
works for me maybe you'll get some ideas
out of what you want to do with your
Tech bag so as a post student that's not
carrying a bunch of books this is what's
in my tech bag so this is the bag itself
it's called the Herschel Pop Quiz
backpack it's somewhat new to me
actually I switched from a slightly
simpler Herschel backpack a couple weeks
ago but just for a couple little better
things as far as interior organization
but it's also red you don't have to get
the red one that screams like red and
black you know you can get a much
simpler color I'll link this below as
well as of course anything else I'll
talk about in this video but basically
you can beat these things up like
they're very durable uh it's also
weatherproof it's got this hood on the
top all the zippers and things like that
are weather resistant so water doesn't
get in you don't want to get this thing
soaked obviously it's still fabric but
it's held up great I toss it around I
throw it in my car every single day no
problem like I said it's definitely not
a tech bag but I like that it doesn't
screen team I have hundreds of dollars
of Technology inside and of course you
can get a more discreet color and like a
gray or a black I was using a gray
before uh but I feel like those bags
that have like a USB port and a solar
panel and like a battery Bank inside
that's a little much you had weight you
add complexity keeping it simple here so
okay inside the main compartment you got
your zippers up top my number one thing
and that's in the back in this laptop
compartment which is actually felt lined
and you got all this this cool black and
white pattern inside too which I
actually think kind of looks nice but
anyway the laptop that is the 13 inch
retina MacBook Pro with touch bar from
last year and it's in this in case
sleeve
with a magnet and I really like the
sleeve actually it's got like this
heather gray look it peels back up here
closes like that with a magnet it holds
the 13 inch MacBook Pro but there's a 15
inch version as well has this sort of
rubber bumpers on the end and goes
through airports like this don't have to
take it out it's great and then the
laptop itself has held up fine I haven't
upgraded to the latest quad core model
because I don't do all that much complex
stuff on this laptop like if I'm
traveling for a video I'm bringing a lot
more stuff including the video editing
laptop which is the 15 inch MacBook Pro
but as far as everyday carry stuff this
the most I'll do on it is some light
photo editing a lot of web browsing
email things like that this is great for
that little dbrand skin on the back
never hurt anybody and it's kept it in
pretty good condition so this is the
daily laptop choice and let's see I also
have my water bottle can never be too
hydrated shout out to all the companies
that include uh stickers in their boxes
that's uh definitely a nice touch and if
I like it it'll probably end up on this
water bottle I also have back here the
MacBook Pro charger this is the higher
wattage charger from the 15 inch MacBook
Pro it just charges the laptop faster so
I use it for the 13 inch MacBook Pro and
also since it's USBC don't tell anyone I
also use it for my phone too that's kind
of the beauty of having one port for
everything hasn't damaged anything as
far as I know yet but USBC among all the
things has been great but then of course
speaking of things that I guess aren't
USBC it's the Bose qc35 headphones of
choice as far as like over ear
especially for traveling getting on a
plane I don't fly without these
headphones they're noise canceling they
have a rechargeable battery but they
charge via micro USB that's the sad part
about them but everything else about
these is amazing and I highly recommend
them so that's pretty much always in the
backpack and then that's like it for the
main compartment this I would say is
like my optional accessories bag which
is not always in the everyday carry but
this is like a zipper bag from Herschel
made to go in their backpacks and it's
got a zipper on the top and if you unzip
this you get a whole bunch of little
Tech goodies inside so first up is this
media drive it's USBC and it is easily
the fastest drive I've ever used it's
the Samsung X5 uh so anytime you need to
do offline media moving it between
machines photos videos raw files
whatever it is I use this now it used to
be the Samsung T5 that everyone would
use and that's still a very popular
drive that I have but this is literally
like eight times faster so any big files
we'll go through this and I also found
these these came from a Dave 2D video
These are basically a full-size USB to
any number of different micro USB
lightning or USB type-c cables so if you
want to charge something say from a
battery Bank plug this end into the
battery Bank plug one of these into what
you want to charge and it will work so
if you forgot your cable or if you need
an extra cable or if someone wants to
borrow one you can give them this and no
matter what phone they have it'll work
then we also have this Anker power bank
I've had this for how many years now
four five years forever I think it's a
20
000 uh 20 100 milliamp hour battery uh
the good thing about it is it's got USB
type-c so if you want to charge it it
uses the same charger as the MacBook Pro
to plug this thing up and Juice It Up
and then there's two full-size USB ports
for again whatever you want this is all
optional this is like if I'm going on a
long flight or if I'm on a long trip or
for doing video stuff I'll toss this in
there too and this backpack also has
this sort of a extra top little sleeve
up here it's microfiber lined I think
it's because you're supposed to put a
phone in it or something like that the
only thing I have in here right now why
am I reaching so far is the air pods I
use which are the matte black everything
ones of course the most beautiful pair
of airpods you've ever seen don't put
your keys in there that is not something
you want to do you don't want to mix
that like kind of defeats the purpose of
the microfiber but that's what I put in
there and then you get to the the least
used front section of this backpack so
up at the front is this like organizer
section I again don't use it very much
but you still got that felt like striped
lining in here and then some pockets for
things like dongles or headphones and
then I have a black lightning cable so
obviously I have a whole bunch of USBC
going on in my life but the iPhone is
not one of those things so this is my
iPhone charger things like contact
lenses business cards and that's it for
that and then the final outside
is some more business cards
a pen
and a little microfiber you can never go
wrong with having a microfiber
what happened to my card reader oh it's
still in here
I almost forgot so I keep this in the
sleeve where the laptop usually is just
because I always use it with my laptop
but this little thing the
Von vanja
I'll link it below because I don't know
what it's called but it's kind of like
the Swiss army knife of media card
readers anytime I need to import photos
or audio from an SD card bam one side is
USB type c but if I'm not about that bam
the other side is full size USB or if
you pull it back
micro USB it is super useful I've let
people don't like borrow this I've used
this many times with my MacBook Pro
micro USB or sorry micro SD cards or SD
cards I love this thing I keep it in the
pocket with the MacBook Pro all the time
it's durable and it's never broken so I
just tossed it in there but that's
basically it that's what I keep in my
backpack every day uh literally that's
that's about it this video is brought to
you by my wallet actually speaking of my
wallet phone wallet keys that's always
the things I have with me wallet is this
Trove slim wallet I'm pretty sure is
what it's called with a little MKBHD
engraved logo on it that's pretty
special edition thanks tro if you guys
are great keys and whatever phones I'm
carrying right now which are as you're
probably wondering OnePlus 6 iPhone 10.
okay that's really it this time thanks
for watching and I'll catch you in the
next one peace